l a tutti ragazzi cazzo mi stanno
cadendo le cuffie in partenza
meravigliosa impartiti da dio bella a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono bravi j
oggi siamo su mi piace dirlo con questa
voce epica eravamo rimasti ragazzi che
eravamo su rapture già aveva fatto
l'inferno
non so neanche come ho fatto a far
l'inferno ma che tira suscita se mia
madre vede come lasciato camera mia e
molto peggio della città stessa credete
un giorno fatto sei figo questo è
successo a già che c'è stata
l'esplosione nucleare eva sei stronzo
dalla vita c'era stata l'esplosione
nucleare che aveva buttato tutto a
per questo c'è la città mezza
distrutta comunque io mi sono fatto un
cazzo non chiedetemi come non chiedetemi
perché però sono morti degli scoiattoli
i ragazzi 20 livelli anche oggi c'è la
possiamo fare crede in me stesso molto
solare questo set di livelli complimenti
non da lì sotto esame giocare a mirror's
edge non so perché mi sembra ti fuori
rope robe a caso e va bene così sì
madonna cosa ho fatto madonna madonna
madonna madonna justin bieber madonna a
questo fattore che cosa ho fatto
e andiamo la cosa pazzesca va beh vedo
una luce ragazzi che non è gesù a dovevo
usarla tra l'altro se non posso andare
sul fantastico e l'utilità di questa
cosa
morirà niente devo morire ragazzi
l'importante è che io muoia piano piano
piano ok ok importante che ci riusciamo
poi non so come non lo so ma mi sono
salvato visse quel salvato lusso come si
ok ok ok outbound sono e sono due e sono
due sono mai stati casi nati questi
ragazzi perché sono enormi
bravo come ho fatto un uso già fatto
ma dai ma come come ho fatto a morire
così tali arrivo fin qua ci arrivo per
il resto non lo faccio a meno che non
per chi ha un cervello questi non c'era
il cervello non abbastanza giustificata
da questo punto di vista credo sia anche
nel caso riuscisse a salvare la tizia
come ca in che mondo la faccio vivere
che è tutto saltato in aria io e il mio
uccello ci siamo leggermente incazzando
non è il mio uccello ma quello che ho in
testa
ecco ma perché ma perché scazzo hai la
mia vita di più adesso sto scrivendo
stella me come se niente fosse ma ci
sono cioè rendetevi conto che non è così
semplice di quella vacca trojan
ragazzi non chiedetemi come ho fatto non
lo so non saprei rispondermi non ne ho
la più pallida idea ma va bene così ci
ho messo un minuto per far questo
livello invece che 13 secondi ma forte
sega importante esserci riuscito così a
sismica nei muri fantastico e vabbè la
madonna e sui casino perché in un centro
il buco ragazzi adesso ho centrato
perché due book is meglio che one più a
destra zio più a destra bravo a te tanta
tanta nutella è na figata sto coso che
si scansano i muri e fantastico solo che
non ho capito il perché c'è non ha senso
bravo bravo mi sta piacendo bravo cosa
cazzo fai zio non sei superman ok ok
adesso dobbiamo chiarirci piazza affari
su cosa qua serviva a staccare il muro
fantastico che cazzo ne so io ok ok va
bene così volevo prendere del tempo
prima ho capito che non andava bene
quindi va bene così
devo fare molto la chiave di una
chiave dai dai
bravo bravo zio ci voleva tanto no hanno
piano piano piano prendi lo prendi lo
hai preso lei veramente preso ma che
cazzo fai quando ti dico di saltare non
salti ti bevi infetto sì l'ho preso vai
vai vai indietro indietro se non riesce
a tornare dietro t'ammazzo la famiglia
t'ammazzo la famiglia ci si bravo bravo
bravo zio ok perfetto vedi che
immaginare la famiglia morta funzionerà
mi stai veramente piacendo sono
orgoglioso che casino adesso livello
cazzo faccio fermi un attimo madonna e
vabbè ma impossibile evidente tutto a
scendere fantastico il problema è che
morirò 2 miliardi di volte ma ok vai vai
silvio non mi deludono mi delude no mi
deludere zio mi stai di ludendo vuoi che
muore temi voi se vi sembra normale
perché a me veramente ma mettiamoci
anche gesù che passa non lo so se
ragazzi non siamo neanche a metà era è
una tragedia
madonna si ok ok no no si è bravo cosa
ho fatto non lo sono anch'io ci siamo
fissiamo piano adesso piano perché tua
madre brutta è veramente una brutta
forte c'era qualcuno che sarà uscito una
volta dicendo che bello facciamo super
meat boy secondo tutto madre ti entra
nell'esofago proviamo ma perché ma
perché è alta tanto odio mio ma ci
voleva tanto oddio mi supera ragazzi cè
un maniaco dovuto semina romania come
ancora con la maniaci ma che cazzo solo
vogliono stuprarmi ragazzi però non
posso permetterlo perché una reputazione
di maniaci di merda bravo zio a caso ma
dai ma vero l'ho fatta ma anche arrivati
al decimo non so con che criterio perché
non saprei di farlo che possono fare la
divina ma cosa critico a vado di qua no
non vado di qui c'è una roba chiedevo
rompere ma non ho capito come e quando
fare qualcosa ragazzo non lo fa ace la
chiave ivy the law che ne so io
si è fatta vabbè non i quali importante
esserci riusciti forte sega come il tuo
come non detto c'è l'ho saltato
di brutto prima non so come non chiedete
ok ok solo fare qua ma è così che si fa
il sugo fantastico ragazzi quando fa
lanciate la pasta al sugo sappiate che
era testo per miccoli
devo cristo nare un attimo su devi
andare su su vuol dire su non vuol dire
tua mamma vuol dire subito vado su su
cos'è che non capisci della parola su
jobs stronzo quei due sono morti grazie
a dio
si ok non riuscirci non riuscisse me ne
frega un cazzo
sì sì sì sì che livello incasinato è
questo sismica nei ponti ci mancava solo
questo balliamo zio vuoi ballare e bravo
affetto bravissimo bravissimo cosa
facciamo muoio io salto qua ok ok
bravissimo no che mira di merda
bye bye bye bye bye bye salta ma perché
i problemi al cervello chelsea bravo
salta salta si e ci voleva tanto gesù
santo spiegano cosa cazzo ci vuole
nervoso li sto gioco che milano una cosa
incredibile di torino che questo pc
pucci posso prenderti no esistono
sembrati bombaci nello ragazzo non lo so
l'importante che io ci riesca a passare
da poi yemen e football si o dio
oddio cosa ho fatto ragazzi voglio
replay subito ho creduto tutta la vita
di essere spacciati ma e non so con
quale culo invece ci sono riuscito va
bene così niente domande e rande grande
così ai marshmallow anni prima di torino
come stai se mica cattivo novero aiuti
fa vj tu non voglio sapere se invece sei
un brutto schifoso donna come lo scriva
adoriamo so neanch'io merda mi segue e
mi segue vuole stuprarmi carica miss
tronto carica mi bravo bravo che bella
mila che c'è anche tu e madonna
sì l'ho preso l'ho preso preso ma che vi
caricano di carica ok ok carica mi
capita mica mente no no a questa stoffa
calmo stai calmo stai calmo stai calmo è
che calca al massimo è caldissimo e
subito si si oh dio va bene che si
stronzo proprio cosa devo fare adesso
non so bravo bravo
era tanto difficile c'è la neve c'è la
neve è sono morto l'importante ragazzi
non essere investiti l'ala ne va
credo che sia la neve perfetto e vabbè
ma che bordello è ma come si fa il
possibile non c'è non ci passerebbe
neanche uno stuzzicadenti laden come
cazzo ci passo io che mi metto a giocare
a dei giochi che mi fanno incazzare
prima di andare a dormire che non dormo
orc caccia o che ha inventato
sto gioco morisse il cane ok non si può
fare non si può fare sì sì sì allora
ragazzi non è così tragico come come
finale forse ce la possiamo fare
manca manca un pene come so che tua
mamma fa i vigneti e non voglio
disturbarla non disturbiamo tua mamma
facciamo le cose per bene
[Musica]
dove devo andare quando sono qui
spiegamelo dove cazzo vado e non c'è la
strada di qua faccio paura da solo
quando lo rifaccio miliardo di volte che
so perfettamente dove morire quindi non
ci muoiono e disagio a bravo credo sia
l'ultimo prima del boss
basta dopo questo annunciamo il non
voglio più vedere nient'altro io non ho
ancora capito sti cosi come cazzo
funzionano e si capta rand yard non so
se si vede non so se si vede dalla mia
faccia ragazzi ma sto smaltendo questo
cazzo di livello sto veramente smazzando
immobile il mobile e immobile in morbido
ciro ciro immobile
ok forte e gesù non ci sto credendo
donna che disastro assurdo ce l'abbiamo
fatta guarda che non è non farò mai più
una roba così credetemi che è che è
successo
sistri che cazzo fa è successo e dolce
stavo scherzando lavati i denti chiaro
va prontamente sonno e va bene tutti i
naruto per la moltiplicazione le corde
nicchia non dorme più regasto por
cristiano barica non sopravvivere mentre
questi mi saltano addosso
che roba orribile ma veramente dio
schiacciamosche solo scattavo bisogna
fare ragazzi continuare sistemi che
questi stronzi mi saltano addosso sono
sempre più strani sti boffo non li
capisco ma io ho capito regalano fermi
natio chiari e intelligente che ci bagna
ecco ecco ecco un cazzo vai vai vai zio
ma zio schiantati schiantate i bastardi
e non per tito padre lo deve prendere
rigorosamente al cuore come cazzo fatto
il titolo che non ci riuscirò metti
nella vita
uno è andato in partenza va beh non ha
preso ma marc coma è mark che
cristo di cuffee inutili senza audio
frega cazzi ragazzi con due sono
convinto come la vita che non ci
riuscirò mai moquette tuca tuca tuca
tutti nel culo tutti 123 non c'ho tre
mani però immaginate che ce l'abbia
addio che goduria
che goduria pazzesca vasta trojan bella
ragazza che si fa rapire ogni volta
questa volta sono letteralmente
impazzito per fare sta roba quindi non
cagate mi il bene è stato veramente
assurdo di end lo farò più avanti
ragazzi perché oggi sono veramente
cotton oncia stavo più facendo basta non
voglio vedere super meat boy finché non
prendo 12 tisane nell'arco della
settimana cosa che farà molto presto
quindi ragazzi concluso che episodio
sono veramente esasperato questa volta
perché porta non c'è verso è
stato veramente tragico stasera prova
bene spero che ai video vi sia piaciuto
però gli piace che mettete una tisana in
più per il povero favi che tanto deve
prenderne 12 prima di domani sono non
dormo un cut i ragazzi servito è
piaciuto la sega assortimento mi piace
anche al presente di facebook con ogni
video tra tale iscrizione per sempre si
distrae tricicli diavolo prossimo vinto
dai ragazzi
[Musica]